on this episode I'm live-streaming while
I'm doing the episode and I answer
questions about the new yo app and a
couple other things that I can't
remember now you ask questions and I
answer them this is the askgaryvee show
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
you're watching and listening to episode
76 of the ask gary vee show
speaking of listening it I want to as a
matter fact this is actually perfect I'm
actually live-streaming a merkat is that
I got a hit up you used to believe oh I
know the guys we're actually looking at
it may even invest in it it's pretty
interesting anyway we're streaming live
so I'll actually talk to you guys as
well at marquette I'm looking for people
to leave reviews to the podcast of the
askgaryvee show so all of you listening
to the show right now one thing I
realized that I need to do to bump it up
so this is a not a question today this
is a request of the day which we have
couldnt get a request of the day look
you know what I haven't done it you got
to give me credit for 76 episodes I
think I did one or two others but like
the request of the day is if you are
listening to this especially on iTunes
by the way thrilled to get one star and
you saying this show sucks crap balls
that's fine I respect that but the
review itself actually matters and so a
veiner nation please hook me up there
Merc in mafia get in here and that's
that had a great weekend spend a ton of
time with the kids that was phenomenal
we posted the Monday motivational video
this morning I think I'm just gonna do
that every Monday though d-roc I think
we should just tape but I do you think
we should tape an original Monday
motivational video every Monday on that
corner I kind of feel there's something
there so if I'm around next Monday am i
if I'm around everybody like blanks if
I'm around next Monday let's just do
another one I think we should just do it
and I'll just do new versions of being
angry at people that are not happy about
their Monday are you my calendar yet
yeah am i here I'm in Vegas all right
that's good
but I'm available the next following
Monday so well do the 16th let's get
into the show Jason asks how do you know
how much time to give to clouds versus
dirt is it based off your personality
and strengths example if you are gifted
to lead and set the vision should you
spend less time doing the work even
though you also like it just as much
the clouds and dirt debate is a super
tough one obviously for people that
follow me in Dirac and the finite but
that was really just you yeah take the
credit you rock do you rock me an
incredible film let's actually link that
up right here or take over I don't know
what you do these days it's just really
my thesis of how I build businesses how
I live life right focus on the big big
big things but don't get scared to get
your hands dirty because execution
matters ideas are [ __ ] without the
execution and vice versa don't play in
the middle that's the real concern and
so I think you know I think you need a
healthy balance to me I can give you a
good answer here I'm uncomfortable this
is one man's humble opinion I'm
uncomfortable if you go 70/30 in any
direction right like if you're over
indexing seventy or thirty in any
direction that's a problem to me so
stick to minimum 70/30 clouds and dirt
yes I do think you need to map your DNA
if you're a big thinker big-time thinker
fine you want to play 70 there still
have the humility and the practitioner
skills to bang out a 30 percent here if
you don't think you're as big of an idea
you think you're grinding and your
hustle is a big factor or there's an ebb
and flow right so like sometimes I'm in
70/30 mode and then I'm in 3070 mode
because the 70 was right and now I have
to execute as a man in fact right now I
feel with vaynermedia the last nine
months I was 70 execution but I'm
feeling myself moving up to like 90
thinking 10 execution because I need to
reach chart the course of the company
because I'm seeing that vulnerabilities
I'm seeing opportunity and that puts me
on the offense so I don't think there's
a perfect breakdown of clouds and dirt
they just always need to be in play and
really I don't think of them as a
day-to-day basis I think of them more
holistically as a true commitment both
the strategy and the dirt that you need
under your fingernails in execution way
too many prima donnas right now I'm the
thinker think this hey Gary Vee big and
Barnum here for big at Barnum's bubble
boiling garden with a pork question for
it yeah my right hook is watch my web
series what are some appropriate I
should have stretched jazz actually know
what's the phone once you do a little
walk around the office right now this
way they'll miss the
question so that'll make them have to
watch it later and then they can also
see a bunch of Bainer stuff bigad first
and foremost have a hardcore WWF naughty
fan growing up you feel like a wrestler
and this is a wrestler promo and that
feels amazing to me I just love that
look I look I I want people to by the
way you know it's so funny that's what I
want I want people to go to
garyvaynerchuk.com
you know I want that and I want people
watching my content
get in here Stefan and I I want those
same things and so I think that content
itself is the jab right so put out micro
pieces of content I'm a big believer and
I look I think that I'm hitting a golden
era in my content production live
streaming my snapchat stories game is up
my Instagram game is up my twitter is
still on point my facebook fanpage
content is up LinkedIn is is stronger
than it was before
Pinterest were still lagging we need to
really get our Pinterest game out right
my library yeah I know but we're don't
let me now see not library you know
Pinterest needs to get up a little bit
but you need to put out micro contents
the reason I wrote Jab Jab Jab right
hook is to get you to put out different
little pieces of content that still
thematically ladder back up to what
you're doing on your website that are
contextual for the platform baguette
don't get lazy on me your big ad go out
there and put out content across the
board and and don't just make it
remember the jabs need to be jabs don't
just make the content where you're like
my biggest idea ever is dot dot dot go
to my website your website will get
traffic as a byproduct and you were able
to throw right hooks and those social
platforms but put out jabs of value to
the audience where they actually spend
their time beget they love you and they
look they want to go to your website but
they rather more than being on your
website be in all these other places and
it's up to you to be there and use that
as a gateway drug to get them back Lori
asks when you have a new idea for your
business how long does it take you to
implement do you run with it
strategize for a while consult with
others
Laurie this is really interesting
because I've actually lived this now in
my 39 and half years of my life I'm
getting close to 40 boy it's starting to
freak with me you know look there's been
businesses that I've sat on in my mind
for such a long time before they get
executed years sometimes even as they
marinate and get refined then there's me
and Jerome Jarre have dinner and
literally the next day there there's
grape story and we have a talent agency
representing vine celebrities so to me
they've run both of the gamuts me and AJ
spent 9 10 11 12 months trying to figure
out what we were gonna do we're gonna
you know a little known fact
before starting vaynermedia we were
probably on third base on starting a
fantasy sports site right which would
have probably been a good idea or a deal
a day site which would also been a good
idea as the early days of Groupon and
LivingSocial so we picked the wrong one
but but we marinated maybe maybe it
didn't come out as good as we wanted but
I will take Vayner as a consolation
prize so really I think it comes down to
the idea it comes down to the timing
I've got ideas that are running through
my head now bad timing I'm running too
much stuff I'm doing too many things at
once you know this whole content team
was probably a you know I don't know how
long was I talking to you before we even
started like how long was it being
flirted about or was that just in my own
mind it was just you it evil you know I
know but before it was just me and you
like how long was I like hey Steve I'm
thinking about something six yeah I mean
it was six months before I literally
probably and that probably means 12
months then Steve started for a year and
then it started rolling with all the
other characters so you know I just
think it comes down to the idea but more
importantly for me because I'm always
rolling with ideas it's the timing am I
prepared don't forget I've often
answered that the biggest failures in my
business career have been when I've been
off more than I can chew I'm in the
process of it right now
faithbox resi vayner/rse brave
vaynermedia my personal brand there's a
lot going on right now and I'm trying to
hold up all these balls and we'll see
what happens hey Gary Vee it's your old
friend Nicole lapin
not only that don't get crazy here's my
question why do you think men should
aspire to date a rich [ __ ] hey Nicole
big shout out to you I know your books
out I took this question because you are
an old great friend and I wanted to give
exposure to your new book so d-roc let's
link that up stephane whatever let's
link up that I know you're doing super
well with your book and I think we
talked a little bit about it the book is
about really financial stability and
financial smarts I think that a man
should marry a rich [ __ ] or be in that
situation or a woman should marry a rich
a [ __ ] dude for the for the same
reasons that you know having a stable
financial partner is always a good
decision in life right like that you
know people that are unable to manage
their money deal with so much stress and
money is not the most important thing
but when you don't know how to handle
that there's an enormous amount of
stress that comes along in life and it's
not about how much you make I mean
there's plenty of people who know how to
manage their money making thirty seven
thousand dollars a year and have a lot
less stress than people that make 140
thousand dollars a year and don't know
how to manage to me I'm anti stress
money management is at the tippy top of
the list probably right below the health
and well-being a family and that would
be the core reason yo Gary Vee what do
you think of the new and improved yo app
is it worth it for my small business
food truck and restaurant
via this deliciousness out for the world
answer my question thank you Greek my
great question
[ __ ] answer which is I haven't looked at
the new and improved yo app thus I can't
give you a real answer I'm not even
really sure why I mean they've accepted
the question knowing that my answer was
such crap
it was probably mainly because I loved
the video and wanted to give you the
exposure and the shout out that comes
along with being on the show but it also
gives me an opportunity to kind of
answer the question as a whole which is
look communicating I have a call right a
phone call what type right now yeah
alright I need to run this is super
important let me just wrap this up you
know at the end of the day communicating
with your audience is the number one
thing that you should be doing at all
times that if you feel like the yo app
brings you value and your audience value
then you should do it you should do that
the meerkat you Steve
you know snapchat Instagram Twitter
Tumblr Pinterest Facebook whatever you
think actually communicates and has an
ROI at the time that you put against it
to communicate about the exposure of
eating a beautiful gyro do that question
of the day how many siblings do you have
and what are their names I like mine
that's why I want that question you can
ask some questions I'll keep answering
them
come on what are they saying in there
nothing looks like what's going on the
chat they like it well I don't know yet
it's early just feeling it out is it
pronounced meerkat yeah is that a
meerkat that's an actual that's an
actual thing that wasn't I'm like
there's no names let's come up with
something I swear I swear the Jets I've
never heard of meerkat how many people
have heard of a meerkat before let's
[ __ ] all right guys
guess I didn't see that Disney movie
let's move on Steve Steve a little rusty
well no no I get it I get it but I want
the whole thing good oh I don't need it
for that but I need it for this
prime times and Dion for example if
you're gifted to lead and set the vision
no don't do that cuz then my bad spot
just kidding
no 7076 hopefully Jack's right
[Music]